un contrôle et raideurs faiblesses
musculaires ne sont que quelques-uns des
symptômes de parkinson
cette maladie provoque la destruction
des neurones producteurs de dopamine et
pour envoyer son développement le
diagnostic doit être posée très tôt ce
qui est rarement le cas d'une personne à
l'autre
les symptômes diffère beaucoup par
exemple j'avais déjà des problèmes de
constipation les problèmes de somnolence
des problèmes de chutes j'avais les à
l'appel de l'oat 4 av
si j'avais su que c'était des symptômes
à ce moment peut-être que le diagnostic
soit posé plus tôt c'est beaucoup de
souffrance au quotidien malgré les
traitements bien c'est beaucoup beaucoup
d'ennuis beaucoup d'incertitude on ne
sait pas comment sera le matin et puis
on a une fatigabilité très très dense ce
matin les familles juives
une conférence en direct de paris
l'information est vitale pour les
malades assis chacun est invité à
participer aux ateliers organisés
localement on y enseigne de nombreuses
astuces comme pour ne pas chuter par
exemple et l'on pratique ensemble le
sport adapté il dit et on peut dire que
le canapé c'est vraiment soit l'ennemi
ça dépend comment on ne prend au alors
l'amie de parkinson parce que la
dégradation physique sera d'autant plus
rapide comme on ne va pas bouger par la
marche nordique par exemple on met le
chien l'equilibre là le balancement on
utilise aussi la technique des danses
traditionnelles vous travaillez sur l'
équilibre de façon ludique
nous avons ici un atelier de
réflexologie et de détente qui permet de
prendre en charge la douleur de façon
autonome gérée la perte d'autonomie
et l'isolément qui en découle est un
poids partagé par les proches à partir
de mai des ateliers seront proposés à
tous pour mieux organiser un quotidien
compliqué ya la lenteur il ya le
déplacement difficile
elle est au risque de chute en plus de
sa vie a dit ça au niveau de la voix
c'est pas toujours évident qu'on pour
battre huchon
il ya des hallucinations et dans mon cas
personnel meta est débloqué donc elle
peut plus marcher docker est-ce que vous
vous sentez vous j'avais bien du 16 kg
bon et puis à maintenant on s'y habitue
et finalement que l'apache est aussi il
est la fobio avec rompre l'isolément des
familles est une priorité
ainsi les ateliers pour les aidants
totalement gratuit débute le 17 mai ils
viennent donc compléter les ateliers
thérapeutiques déjà organisées chaque
semaine